hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
zu einer weiteren folge agrio ich habe
diese website namens al arab al gaddafi
habe ich hier kann man auf jeden fall
ganz normaler cabrio zocken allerdings
sind die teile die man hier frisst viel
viel größer ich bin grad total eingeengt
irgendwie das heißt man ist viel
schneller irgendwie in den top ten
wenn ich es überhaupt schaffen sollte
das ist halt einfach der sinn von diesem
savadori heilige was mache ich denn hier
oh mein gott ich hatte erst irgendwie
danach geschaut dass ich irgendwie einen
empty server finde also einen leeren
server auf dem ich dann irgendwie
versuchen kann
erster zu
jedenfalls habe ich da jetzt eine halbe
stunde nach gesucht und würde überhaupt
nicht fündig das heißt freuen ich bin
auf euch angewiesen wenn ihr irgendwo
möglichkeit habt oder ist wie ich ab 1
wenn ihr wisst wie oder ob es überhaupt
möglich ist auf einen and server zu
zäunen oder sich da irgendwie was zu
holen oder so hin schreibt mir das mal
bitte in die kommentare weil ich meine
fresse ist er groß ich finde es
unglaublich cool mal mit euch auf einen
empty server zu zäunen und dann was
macht den kern des tod mit euch zusammen
auf einem server zu können um dann dort
irgendwie zu alleine zu spielen oder
dass ich da ganz alleine spielen weil
ihm kein bloß auf mich ich war auf allen
möglichen websites ich war auf
türkischen auf arabischen auf allen und
überall stand mir bringt dich auf einen
drive it server nein es hat nicht
geklappt deswegen habe ich mich jetzt
für diesen server entschieden um
vielleicht in die top ten zu kommen was
ich allerdings nicht bedacht habe ist
das ja dann jeder diese voraussetzungen
hat deswegen bin ich noch immer nicht in
den top-ten ach guck mal diese
kleinteile sind genauso groß wie wenn
ich eins von mir selber wegging
das ist interessant tunnel soll die ich
noch gefressen und jetzt
v der sich ott kleingemacht heimmarkt
kannst du vielleicht wenn meinen bauch
kommen denn ich bin da das heißt auch
man kann sich viel schneller wieder
zusammen saugen also man geht nahezu
komplett schnell wieder zusammen das
jetzt positiv oder negativ ist weiß ich
nicht ich muss bei weimar wieder zum
friseur die haare sind
sehr lang du willst aussehen wir nicht
mehr diesmal zu anderen okay lass es
auch kommen
sind da
nein nein
aber schaut manchmal von fünf minuten
auf dem platz sieben ich gehe einfach
mal wieder auf dem server drauf
und bin direkt tot ich bin gerade auf
facebook account und schaut euch diese
verdammte scheiße an
wie groß sind diese teile die ich essen
kann ach du heilige scheiße
wo bin ich denn hier gelandet wie krank
ist das bitte ich oh mein gott da ist
der mond wo meine fresse was passiert
hier was ist das für ein kranker modus
hier ich bin unfassbar riesig und bin
noch immer nicht in den top-ten ich will
gar nicht wissen wie der erste aussieht
okay ich bin jetzt zehnter ich bin nicht
mehr zehnter ich bin wieder zehnter naja
ich kann mich gerade auf jeden fall
nicht zusammen saugen irgendwie und es
fakt mich gerade ich gesagt ein bisschen
ab ach du heilige scheiße ich habe aber
der preis da mein sichtfeld ist auch gar
nicht eingeschränkt gerade durch diese
größe ich habe einen score von 14.000
gerade ich bin schon unglaublich riesig
aber ich traue mich gar nicht zu
splitten weil ich weiß dass die anderen
es gibt auch sechs sollte die größer
sind als ich und ich hab schon und score
von 14.000 man ich wusste dass es
passiert es war einfach klar meine
fresse es ist trotzdem einfach viel zu
krank was hier gerade passiert
was ist das für ein kranker server jungs
ich will euch echt nicht stressen aber
könnt ihr euch vielleicht mal wieder
zusammen saugen das wird mir definitiv
der bauer
while zum glück bin ich nicht klein das
ist nicht mehr normal wie viele von
diesen scheiß teilen ihr überall
rumliegen
ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen wie
viele schließzellen liegen herum die ich
verdammt nochmal fressen kann volk ist
das geil ich habe noch gar keinen neuen
gegessen und ich bin trotzdem in den top
ten und habe nur diese kleinen scheiß
zellen gefressen brauchst du heilige
scheiße ich bin fünfter computer ist
pedrosa sp zuschauer das werben
das wäre dort hat man ein risiko gaal
meine fresse ich bin dritter der moment
ist gekommen an dem ich mich überhaupt
nicht mehr bewegen kann
ich weiß gar nicht wo ich hinfahre okay
es war klar dass das passiert es war
doch einfach ich bin erst da ich bin
vierter ich habe mich gar nicht mehr
unter kontrolle irgendwie ich weiß ich
stehe einfach nur noch auf der stelle
das ist nicht so mein gott was passiert
gerade ich weiß überhaupt nicht was
passiert ich bin auf jeden fall erster
aber
ich kann mich nicht mehr steuern so
richtig v dieser komische mit dem
komischen gittermuster kommt niemanden
neu
hey ich habs komplett abgesagt
freundlich opfere mich jetzt mal ihm
hier der ist jetzt erst ich hatte eine
heißt es von 52 1840 wenn euch das video
gefallen hat würde ich mich sehr über
eine bewertung freuen wenn ihr eine idee
haben wie ich irgendwie auf einen leeren
server dienen kann man schreibt mir
gerne die kommentare und dann sehen wir
uns wieder
leider